[Music]
time now for final exam where the news
experts compete to see who's been paying
the closest attention to the news this
week tonight a special the five edition
of final exam Jesse Watters and Greg
Gutfeld two names you may be familiar
with join us for the largest city in the
United States tonight the winner will
face off next week this is literature
with a 12-time jeopardy champion in the
mean time we want to address directly
the unsubstantiated allegation present
on mr. Gutfeld t-shirt our judges and
we're not gonna weigh in one way or
another on this they are saying they are
not going to deduct points preemptively
for the insult that you have thrown at
mr. water so we're just gonna leave it
at that if that's all right fake news
sucker fake news I'm not you know I
don't get involved in the hair question
I thought it was actually having a
rematch with Dana okay you guys know the
rules so if I'm gonna repeat them for
our viewers just tuning in now from the
real jeopardy so you hands on buzzers I
ask the questions the first one to
buzzing gets to answer the question you
must wait until I finish asking before
you answer you can answer what's I
acknowledge by saying your name every
correct answer is worth one point get it
wrong you lose a point best of five wins
that's what we call journalism math
simple you guys ready yeah all right
let's get started question one which
television billionaire who was named
after a biblical figure just lost 50
million dollars on a Weight Watchers
investment after fewer people signed up
for its diets Oprah Winfrey Oprah
Winfrey you know that he hid before the
question ended oh you know I can't I'm
not there our judges are gonna have to
assess you guys are in the metropolis
2200 miles sir okay the buzz counts
that's what they say all right was it
Oprah Winfrey fifty million dollars
that's how much Oprah is losing after
Weight Watchers stock plunges Oprah owns
part of the company which blames the
stock drop unless people signing up for
its program I hope you didn't pay an
analyst for that an evaluation Oh kill
me
can I ask you guys did you know that
Oprah was a biblical name no I didn't
know that I didn't know there but I'm
gonna piss compelling so I guess I won't
it's Harpo backwards and the Mars a
brother in a studio where there's were
in the Old Testament yes it may have
written it was a very brutal brutal trio
of brothers okay hands on buzzers
question two this is multiple choice so
wait till you get all the options okay
the president's working lunch with the
dictator of North Korea in Vietnam
featured a very interesting menu the
dessert consisted of a certain vegetable
in a light sugary syrup was it a green
beans B wood ear mushrooms or C Chinese
water chestnuts that mushrooms
it was much woody ear Mun that sounds
repulsive but was it would ear mushrooms
listen to this for the finish a
traditional Vietnamese dessert of lotus
seeds and mushrooms white sugary syrup
oh how did you know that I'm actually a
chef you know that yeah I didn't know
that I cook almost every night for the
children you know I got out of the
orphanage and I cook for the children
I'm a selfless human being you and
Richard Branson okay question three
yet another multiple choice 20/20
candidate Amy Klobuchar of Minnesota's
in the news for her strange behavior
while dealing with her staff one former
aide recalls a time when he witnessed
the senator eating her salad with which
unusual item was it a a pair of scissors
was it be a comb or was it seeing her
bare hands
Greg guma comb not her bare hands was it
a comb the New York Times supporting any
club which are berated a staff member at
an airport back in 2008 for failing to
bring her a fork with her salad so
senator klobuchar ate the salad using a
comb from her bag then handed the comb
to her aid and told him to clean it hey
Tucker yeah I knew that
Tucker yeah do you know what the
collusion story and Amy Klobuchar
haven't
what a dirty Comey it's pretty good
scotch and sprite question for which
loud member of Congress who used to be a
bartender is now featured as a sword
wielding superhero in a cringe inducing
comic book MC Greg Gutfeld a OSI can you
be more specific
now the injury Octavia Cortes was it a
oh say it's a bird it's a plane it's a
OC New York congresswoman is now the
stars in the freshman one cover shows
the Democratic Socialist with a sword
and superwoman style outfit with the
caption the party who dis so we have two
notes three two one we have two notes
from our judges one keep hands on
buzzers okay and second this final
question is worth two points you
[Music]
marionette control just telling you I do
what I'm told
this is exactly do we do something by
the way never apologize never explain
therefore I won't find your question
it's because they don't like you Greg if
you wish your beer tasted more like
marshmallows you're in luck tonight a
Virginia brewery is now selling a beer
that tastes like which sugary breakfast
cereal Lucky Charms
but is that sure let's check the tape
watch them like a bar
lucky Charlie beer Saturday morning IPA
is made of toasted marshmallows and
fruity calypso ha so impressive you'll
even see a leprechaun - yeah Greg
Gutfeld you are impressive I will give
you my Eric wimp Alma next time I see
you you're gonna face off against a
12-time jeopardy champion good luck all
the answers buzzer our producer Justin's
bringing you a mug write to your office
right now thank you gentlemen that's it
for this week's final exam
tune in next week and see if you can
beat the experts gutfeld
is the jeopardy champion whoa